morpho cameroun et ma fille est ce que
quelqu'un aurait vu n'y aurait ni
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en guerre trente ans dans le
futur
c'est quoi ce truc tu apprennes mines
n'est pas humain il faut que vous veniez
vous battre tu as été enrôlés je vais
revenir
pourquoi tu dois partir tu as la
dispense pour les enseignants et celle
pour les référents si j'y vais pas ils
vont envoyer à ma place c'est quelque
chose devait m'arriver
il y voyait toi vous serez à l'abri si
il devait arriver quelque chose
70% des enrôlés ne reviennent pas
parfois nombeux savoir ce qui est le
mieux pour sa famille pas pour lui-même
retiré votre chemise s'il vous plaît
c'est pourquoi tout ça c'est juste un
test
une ceinture alors c'est un test de
conduite alors vous connaissez pas
l'humour dans le futur
ce dispositif vous permet de passer dans
le futur et d'en revenir vois tu le met
dans ce sens là pourquoi tu as l'air si
tu as c'est une longue histoire et un
ancien militaire ouais c'était pas si
l'on en fait
dans à peine qu'on soit
auront disparu de la surface de la terre
à mois que faut même 5e
j'essaie seulement de sauver ma fille il
doit sauver le monde tu peux me croire
je le ferai
[Musique]
s'était remis leur race humaine
disparaître ap la surface de la terre
nous vivons littéralement à crédit
nous reste une chance d'empêcher que
cette guerre se produisent alors on doit
se battre
c'était sympa de vous connaître les gars
[Applaudissements]